how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
the mcu's phase four is moving forward
full blast right now
it started with one division even though
it wasn't supposed to but it did and it
set up the more
mystic side of the mcu and that's what
we're going to be revisiting
in doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness then we had the falcon and the
winter soldier which is the more
grounded side of the mcu it gave us our
new captain america
sam wilson and it laid the groundwork
for the new avengers to come in
and now we have loki which is pretty
much going to shatter the entire
universe leading us
right into spider-man no way home and
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and the next step of phase four
is apparently
mutants we have a couple of
confirmations for a few different
mutants coming to the mcu
in phase four in certain movies that
we'll talk about and i also have a
theory on how the mutants
actually came to be a thing in the
marvel cinematic universe
and for those of you who are wondering
yes i believe that they have been
in the mcu the entire time but i'll
break it all down
if you love marvel and want to stay up
to date on all things happening in the
mcu be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
so let's start with the two mutants who
are already confirmed to be coming to
the mcu one of them was just
recently confirmed and it's who
everybody wanted to see
appear in black panther 2 wakanda
forever and of course it is
namor it was reported last week by the
illuminerty.com
that namor is going to be in wakanda
forever and they even reported that the
actor that marvel has cast to play him
is tina kuerta so it seems like we have
our neymar but i don't actually think
that he's going to be the villain which
i'll get to in just a bit
but namor is a mutant in the marvel
comics his father
is a human but his mother is atlantean
and she's actually atlantean royalty
which means eventually neymar will go on
to take his place on the throne
now he is a mutant yes he does have some
atlantean powers but his mutant ability
is the ability of flight and a lot of
people were expecting him to be
the villain of black panther 2 but i
don't believe this to be the case i do
think he is going to be somewhat of an
antagonist but i think it might kind of
be like a batman vs superman
godzilla vs kong type of movie the
atlanteans and the wakandans have never
really gotten along that well
however with the illuminati announcing
that tena kuerta is going to be
playing namor in wakanda forever they
also announced two other characters that
are coming in wakanda forever as well
and these two characters are nomura who
is neymar's cousin
and atuma an atlantean warlord
and i think that atuma could be one of
the main villains if not
the main villain of black panther ii and
he will be the common enemy
that namor and whoever takes on the
mantle of black panther in wakanda
forever will have to fight against and i
believe that this is
going to be what kind of unites wakanda
and atlantis
atuma will kind of take half of the army
of atlantis much like killmonger kind of
took
half of the army of wakanda atuma will
then attack wakanda in which neymar and
his followers will help wakanda defeat
atuma
which will also help namor reclaim his
throne this is how i see this happening
although black panther 2 details are
very scarce right now they're keeping
them very secret
but it appears that we know who our
neymar is going to be and that is one
mutant that is going to be coming to the
mcu
in phase four another one that is
confirmed is coming
actually next month in black widow for
the longest time there were rumors that
the mutant ursa
major was going to be appearing in black
widow the actor who goes by the name
the dutch giant who is over seven foot
tall
originally posted to his instagram
stating that he would be playing the
character that was quickly changed to
just say that he is in the film
however david harbour himself who of
course is going to be playing red
guardian in the film
kind of spoiled everything a few weeks
ago in his instagram post a few weeks
ago he said
ursa elena nat cd
sputnik i and all the rest of the winter
guard
look forward to sharing a popcorn bag
and a big old screen in a dark theater
with you on july 9th
the first word he said was ursa which is
ursa major the mutant the person who has
the ability to turn into a giant
bear and of course the other characters
he mentioned are the rest of the winter
guard but let's keep this focused on the
mutants for now
bottom line is he confirmed a mutant
ursa major will indeed be in black widow
so mutants are going to start to be
introduced in the mcu
less than a month from now which is
insanely exciting because obviously with
the fantastic four coming
the actual x-men team will eventually be
coming as well
and that setup is going to begin in
phase 4. i also want to add the
possibility of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness introducing
mutants it is not confirmed to be
introducing any but it is literally
a movie that can do whatever it wants in
a movie that involves the multiverse
there are really no limits
all you have to do is step inside a
different universe and you can do
whatever you want in that universe
because it won't affect
the main mcu however you can bring
things from other universes into our
main universe and then they do
affect our universe so just like toby
maguire spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man can be
taken from their respective universes
and come into ours and help tom hall and
spider-man fight the sinister six
this can happen with mutants as well
right now it's been reported and rumored
by a few trades that ghostwriter is
actually going to be introduced in
doctor strange 2.
and although not necessarily a mutant
he's still a really insanely cool
character
but the bottom line and my point is is
that they can really do whatever they
want
in that movie and it also has been
reported that the illuminati could be
introduced in the mcu pretty soon and
one report says that they're coming in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
now professor x is a part of the
illuminati in the comics but we'll have
to see who the actual
members are when they get introduced
into the mcu now as far as the big
question of have the mutants been a part
of the mcu this entire time during the
infinity saga
i have a theory about this and my theory
says yes and my theory comes down to the
eternal specifically
one eternal and one deviant now we don't
know
all of the details of the eternals yet
however i think i could have figured out
how the mutant gene or the x gene
comes into existence now there are a lot
of theories out there stating that the
celestials did experiments on humans and
that's how the x-men come into play
that's how the eternals were created and
that's how the deviants were created
but i have a little bit more of a
specific theory
there have been reports and leaks for a
while now that states that angelina
jolie's character
athena has a big secret and there was
even a particular scene in the teaser
trailer for the eternals where angelina
was training and she had this weird look
on her face
almost like she was very sad and i think
i could know why
in the comics vena has kids but she has
them with
a deviant which is definitely not
supposed to happen the eternals and the
deviants have been at war with each
other since their creation
but she falls in love with one of them
and they have twins now in the comic
story line she gives them
away she gives them to a human who can't
have kids herself
i believe that this is going to happen
in the movie as well i think that this
is thena's big secret
once upon a time she fell in love with a
deviant had kids
gave them away so these kids are going
to be the offspring of an eternal
which is almost essentially a god and a
deviant which is also a very powerful
being
i believe that these kids could be the
start of the x gene
in the mcu just based off of what their
biological structure could be
take thanos for example thanos is
actually an eternal he was born of two
eternal parents but when he was born he
inherited
the deviant gene so he kind of has both
dna
the dna of an eternal and the dna of
deviants and just look how freaking op
thanos came out
one of the strongest beings in the
universe and trust me in the comics he's
a lot more powerful
than he is in the mcu in the actual
infinity saga comics he crushes not only
the avengers but the x-men and the
fantastic four
just a bunch of different heroes all
coming together to fight him he
completely destroys them and he does
have powers of his own
outside of using the infinity gauntlet
so we could if my theory is correct
essentially have
two kids who are like thanos hopefully
not as ugly but two kids who inherit
these two different
insanely powerful genes perhaps the dna
of an eternal
and a deviant combined could give us
that mutant
gene and remember athena is thousands
and thousands and
thousands of years old if she had her
kids during the time of
babylon that means the mutant gene could
have existed for thousands and thousands
of years
and those kids would go on to mate with
other people and have kids which would
spread the mutant gene which would mean
mutants have been around in the mcu
since almost the beginning of time
now that is just my personal theory
you'll have to let me know what you
think about it in the comments down
below but regardless we have
confirmation that the mutants are coming
in phase four one of them coming in less
than a month in black widow
this is the start of the x-men team
eventually coming down the line so
let me know how excited you are in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest
mutant updates don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof